all right come on let's get upstairs get
dressed so go ahead get dressed and
you'll get a wobble races go upstairs
upstairs Phil you all right Tommy
you got on the wrong foot you ready to
go get some waffles man's gonna go to
high hop yeah we go get some breakfast
so it's just me and Tommy today my wife
and Nathan are coming back from a trip
to Texas I was supposed to go with them
and go catch alligator gar and
smallmouth Buffalo well Becca had a
conference but instead I did a jury
trial and and made money instead of
spending money so financially it was a
great week for fishing wise yeah it was
okay so um we're gonna go grab some
breakfast just me and Tommy and then
we're gonna do some carp fishing I think
you uncle catch a carp
yeah all right let's do it
tell me you ready to have some fun today
I think we're gonna have a good time
[Music]
your dog waffles is going to have
waffles
[Music]
alright Tommy check this out ticket
straw you rip off half of it okay
wash it see there you go buddy there you
did I tell me you liking that yeah
chocolate pancake that's pretty awesome
yeah a little cold looks pretty but it's
cold
we can go carp fishing for a couple
hours at the park and just play around
and go carp fishing or we could go to
the hardware store and I can pick up
some supplies to try to build bow and
arrows would you would you rather do
would you really go to the hardware
store or would you rather go to go
fishing your auntie both well which one
do you want to do first
Harbor starthistle in a row
okay get the stuff in the bow and arrows
all righty let's do it right buddy go
run yeah we made it
everything about this good piece nothing
that works are you just going to sit
down there
having fun aren't you I think he'll I
can tell you dude sorry
alright let's hop in the car everybody
hop in
alright just got set up and shooting a
carp fishing video and Tommy is playing
with the spider-man umbrella on the
playset I'm gonna go check it out
make sure he's doing good oh wish we had
a kite play with that right now
Tommy we love that you're going that one
has a little baby boy how are you come
in mind
I'm bro okay hold on yeah yeah I'll pump
with your legs now you push me higher
and I already not talk Oh Tommy here
that got a little fish bite that one off
okay alright let's go check it out
windy and the cold wind but it's sunny
and the sun's really warm that kind of
weird mix but it's neither than just a
certain pain there you go get blown away
oh you're spider-man umbrellas getting
busted up yeah I don't think you're
supposed to walk on them